Non
Je suis ton père.
Nooooooooon !
Bon ça fait beaucoup d’infos d’un coup,
hein, prends le temps de digérer
Qu’est-ce que je fais, je...
je t’attends là ?
Si vous ne la relâchez pas
Je vous chercherai
Je vous trouverai
Et je vous tuerai !
Ouais ?
Oui bonjour c’est Monsieur Lafont du syndic,
excusez-moi il me semble que vous avez mis une commode sur le trottoir
et nous on est bien embêtés
parce qu’on essaye de passer avec la camionnette
et on n’y arrive pas
Excusez moi,
par contre il devait me ramener chez moi, du coup c’est…
c’est chiant quoi
Je sais que je devrais faire la gueule
mais honnêtement je pouvais pas les blairer
pfff ça commence à me...
Je connais le kung-fu.
Montre moi.
Regarde, je sais faire ça aussi  !
Ok c'est super
on passe au kung-fu ?
Chez le boucher,
il y a un bébé qui regarde un chien,
qui regarde un poulet roti.
voilà, et maintenant on est devant le petit kiosque à journaux,
juste à l’entrée du métro
et moi,
je vous laisse ici.
Euuh attendez !
non mais c’est sympa mais c’est pas là où je voulais aller hein
Ah mais t’as mis des explosifs…
dans ce bâtiment aussi oui…
J'avais oublié
La tuile !
Et regarde ce que je sais faire…
Et hop là !
Tour de magie mon gars !
Super !
Et regarde comment je cours vite !
Et allez on change de style,
envoie la sauce, DJ !
Coupe Machin,
je me suis claqué la cuisse là.
La cuisse !!
D'accord,
donc là c'est un rêve je pense.